[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
I'm really excited I'm really excited
about feeling alcohol okay you haven't
had any yet I haven't had any no really
we're up all right here it is Cheers
Cheers no alcohol to now 31 days
gentlemen we [ __ ] did yes to all you
out there too did it with us cheers
wait a second why did Joe only mention
no alcohol last week I was making a
video on arshafir's new stand-up special
which led me watch his most recent
episode of Tuesdays with stories during
this podcast appearance he told the
whole story of going to see Roger Waters
with Joe Rogan live in Austin and the
religious exemption deal that was
granted to Ari during sober October
we're gonna burn 500 calories a day in
one sitting
and we gotta do a hundred push-ups and
I'm like guys what can you do for me I I
gotta have a religious exemption for
this so I asked for an exemption from
the guys and they said if you add a
hundred sit-ups a day
then you can get a one day one-time
exemption that's totally worth it
yeah and a little unfair I don't feel
like you did sober October let's be
honest with one day off but I didn't
couple it with any
alcohol with weed I just had a religious
girl are you finding some way into a
psychedelic exemption for this concert
is the least bit surprising he
notoriously hates sober October even
drug the guy wants some protests of the
month but Joe Rogan on the other hand
the guy who's always talking about how
seriously he takes competitions and how
important sober October is for you he
would never take a cheat day during such
a holy month so who's going to the
concert me Rogan Tony Tony's girlfriend
two security guards uh Duncan said he's
got tickets from the drummer from Pink
Floyd I don't know he found tickets of
course he knows the Pink Floyd yeah wow
of course right of course uh Jamie uh
was going demo I didn't know and uh so
I'm like I got six into asset I'm like
Tony you doing it no one else would
touch it I told Rogan I'm like hey I got
six exemptions quote unquote he goes
sweet and then I get there and I'm like
here's your asset goes [ __ ] that where'd
you find this and I'm like I found it he
goes no [ __ ] way am I touching that
I'm like what'd you think I meant by
exemptions
he's like I meant weed these are these
guys who are just like they act cool but
they're these nerds that don't do acid
in their 50s you know what I mean the
only other man in that car who would
touch the acid
was Tony hinchcliffe's girlfriend
no Duncan no we weren't with Duncan oh
he went in main gate I guess I don't
know so do you guys have these VIP seats
and everything so that yeah so so in the
car uh Rogan took his exemption I don't
want to rat on him but a little
yeah he so he had to add an extra 500
calories a day or the the he was like we
could do an extra 100 push-ups I can't
even do 100 push-up as it is right
that's embarrassing you could spread
them out oh I do I'm honestly very
surprised this didn't come up at all
during the sober October recap episode
the extra workouts and exercise these
guys had to do in exchange for getting
[ __ ] up to see a legendary concert
totally fair more than understandable
but you got to let the people know I
mean it kind of seems like they were
trying to get away with this one and
also Bert and Tom I'd expect them to
bring that up during the recap episode
unless they had some exemptions that we
also don't know about No One Believes
that Bert was able to do this in the
first place the fact that he wasn't mad
that Joe and Ari both had a day that
they weren't sober and didn't bring that
up on national scale on the on the recap
episode
that doesn't sit well with me also I
think the weed exemption is a little bit
different than the acid exemption for a
few reasons mostly being Joe said a lot
that weed's part of his daily routine
that he's really jonesing for all of
October that I didn't expect to miss it
and crave it this much acid seems way
less common in Ari's life it's not like
he's doing that every day like Joe's
smoking every day he's not on October
8th being like oh [ __ ] dude I really
miss my daily tab right now all right so
you're on acid so I took the acid went
in me and Tony's girlfriend did he's
like I don't know it's not the right
time like there's no better time yeah
this is the right time
mother should I build the wall yeah
also before we move on Welcome Back to
the joke World comedy update every
single week bringing you all the
important information from your favorite
comedians your favorite podcast
literally the entire comedy world all
wrapped up for you in one place today's
Tuesday November 15th usually these come
out every single Monday so please do me
a favor and subscribe to joke world
right now go follow us on Instagram and
go download this episode on Spotify or
apple wherever you listen to podcasts to
support the show thank you if you follow
any of the New York comedians on
Instagram then you've definitely seen
some footage from Mark Norman's wedding
this past weekend in New Orleans
last week we talked about part one of
his we might be drunk bachelor party
podcast episodes Part Two came out last
night and Ari's over 100 000 views some
of the people it features is Joe DeRosa
Shane Gillis David tell and many more
now it's hard for you to break away you
live in deep Jersey you got a wife and
kids I have wife one kid another one on
the way November you're living his life
go ahead tell them about setting up a
trampoline
there I go again
[Laughter]
go check out part two on the we might be
drunk YouTube channel after this video
and congratulations to the happy couple
apparently there's some major backlash
going on right now because Dave
Chappelle hosted SNL last weekend who
could have seen that coming the funny
thing about this is it feels like we're
all being told that there's all this
backlash and controversy surrounding the
Dave Chappelle SNL appearance but I
don't see where any of this is actually
happening in real life like I don't know
who's actually mad about any of this
it's almost like all the major media
Outlets just wrote their story about the
Dave Chappelle controversy before he
even hosted SNL and then just filled in
the reasons that they're mad after the
fact like woke Mad Libs obviously Dave
Chappelle is going to be fine he's a
legend and as a fan I just want to say I
appreciate him still even accepting gigs
like this like he has nothing to gain
from hosting SNL he's already way bigger
than them only things that are going to
happen are negative stories like this
but he's still willing to go out there
do it put himself out there for us for
the fans for himself to get his message
out I don't know why probably a lot of
reasons but I appreciate that he's still
willing to do this even though like I
said he has nothing to gain from SNL
guest spots from last week your mom's
house had on Bobby Kelly two bears one
cave was Bert and Neil Brennan no Tom
flagrant hat on style Bender whiskey
Ginger talked with Blake Anderson and
kiltony had on Tim Dillon you told us
that you got a moped is this true yes I
got a moped like a true Asian that is
incredible I always wondered how you
were gonna die now I know that's very
exciting
have you had any trouble with it yet
I've had trouble picking up chicks
um
it's hard to fit them on there uh
uh I I had a e-bike before and now I
have a moped so I think it's an upgrade
technically okay I returned and when you
say you're into bigger chicks Hans are
we talking about like our guest here
tonight
foreign
Wong
thank you for coming
and what are you dressed as exactly here
I'm Max from Where the Wild Things Are
it's adorable
thank you I don't think I know what that
is yeah you did it's a children's book I
mean they should not sell that costume
to adults like the the FBI should have
taken your phone number when you bought
that
this past weekend was Dana Carvey
tigerbelly did not have a guest The Joe
Rogan Experience had on Graham Hancock
and Randall Carlson very trippy
conversation there we might be drunk as
a bachelor party part two Neil Brennan
was also on are you garbage Bobby Lee
was on impulsive and our shaffir was the
guest on the Tim Dillon show some brand
new comedy specials are out right now
Neil Brennan was on all those podcasts
last week to promote his new special
titled blocks that's on Netflix and
according to their description from a
weird relationship humans have with dogs
to how dating a model is like owning a
dune buggy Neil Brenham uses on his life
in this stand-up special I can never
open a patreon that's what sucks yeah no
we yeah we started when we were four and
now it's you know yeah now but you'll
always be poor to people and I'll always
be rich to people because when they met
me they're like this [ __ ] guy even
though they don't know yeah he's well
you're walking around wearing pink pink
shirts right there right there what do
you got on you like two three grand what
do you carry with I usually like to
carry a lot of cash
[Laughter]
that's all right other specials out
right now Kurt brand Hall perfectly
stupid that description reads an
hour-long comedy special that delivers
all the delightfully absurd and
hilarious joking that a brand whole set
always promises and some other specials
on YouTube Phil Hanley Ooh La La and Ari
shafir Jew available right now like I
said on YouTube that does it for this
week's joke World comedy update as
always thank you for watching and we'll
be back again next Monday with some more
comedy news but in the meantime please
subscribe to joke world right now like
this video comment something for the
algorithm doesn't matter what it is just
comment something maybe comment about
the new studio do you like the new
studio we got this new sign back here
shout out to Ted got the curtains we
still got the old backdrop available so
we might still do some videos from there
but you know still setting up this spot
figuring out the lighting we're gonna
get some cool interviews with some
comedians that are on tour in this spot
so a lot of good things coming down the
pipe from joke world turn on the post
notifications if you don't want to miss
anything thank you so much for watching
check us out on Instagram thank you for
watching I already said that that's
three thank yous you get three thank
yous for watching joke world videos how
many other times are other people
thanking you probably not three thank
you again that's four okay bye
[Music]